I'm not who I used to be.
I'm something more.
It's time I told you the truth
about Leanne Grayson.
When she first came to this house…
it was an act of love.
But that love was a selfish love.
It has brought death
and destruction down upon us all.
People keep getting hurt in this house.
It's Leanne.
When she's happy, things are good.
When she's angry, things go bad.
I'm not who I used to be.
She scares me.
I’m something more.
I hurt people when I get angry.
The scariest part is that I'm starting
to like the way that it feels.
It's her or us.
If she wins…
the city will fall, and that's
only the beginning.
Just when I thought you couldn't
make this any more disgusting
and morally abhorrent.
Do you wanna hear a secret, Dorothy?
Jericho… shhh.